elle tronc nos sommet de l'Europe la
Suisse avec ses montagnes s’école et ses
glaciers un paysage en train de changer
plus rapidement anticipé
Jérémy et Bertrand gentilon sont tous
deux guides de montagne une véritable
passion familiale le père est
spécialiste de bio géographie le fils
complète des études anglaisiologie pour
nous on va pas et moi c'est un endroit
qu'on apprécie vraiment en entendant
dans lequel on est venu souvent pour
faire de l'alpinisme pour faire de la
randonnée c'est super intéressant parce
qu'on peut bien se rendre compte de
l'ampleur des changements de l'impact de
la hausse des températures sur les
glaciers
[Musique]
une petite ascension permettra d'arriver
au pied du glacier du Mont minet au fil
des générations ce géant a perdu de son
immensité en 60 ans il a été imputé de
près de 850 mètres de sa longueur
le recul qui se constate année après
année
ça
correspond pas du tout à l'identité de
cette montagne que j'ai appris à
connaître je dois aussi quand même au
niveau humain dire que ça me folker de
voir ça c'est très impressionnant ce qui
est en train de se passer par la vitesse
le monde dans lequel j'ai grandi il se
transforme à une vitesse que je pouvais
pas imaginer possible auparavant
[Musique]
le phénomène est loin d'être unique
cette année seulement les glaciers de
Suisse ont perdu 6% de leur superficie
deux à trois fois plus que ce qui avait
été constaté les années précédentes trop
peu de neige en hiver pour protéger la
glace et des chaleurs records en été qui
ont accéléré la fonte
le jeune des photos prises à 5 ans
d'intervalles et on voit carrément une
langue de glace qui a disparu le
photographe il a l'air du moulin a voulu
documenter la fonte des glaciers pendant
plusieurs années il a parcouru les Alpes
appareil photo en main sa mission
comparer les décors que l'on voyait il y
a des dizaines d'années avec les
paysages contemporains je trouve c'est
important de montrer ce qui se passe
parce que certains sont dit pas grand
chose les plus anciennes photos que j'ai
c'est elles sont de 1848 et on peut dire
donc durant ces 150 ans 160 ans on voit
finalement ce que ce qui s'est passé et
puis la réalité c'est que c'est vrai que
les glaciers sont en train de
disparaître en fondant la glace révèle
certains de ses secrets ces dernières
années et pas avec corps disparus depuis
longtemps ont été retrouvés le phénomène
a des répercussions géopolitiques la
fonte d'un glacier dans les Alpes a eu
un impact sur la ligne de partage des
eaux démarcation naturelles entre
l'Italie et la Suisse les deux pays ont
donc été contraints de négocier le tracé
de leurs frontières
à moyen ou long terme le recul des
glaciers pourrait aussi faire frissonner
l'économie de la Suisse un pays dont les
paysages alpins attirent chaque année
plus de 10 millions de touristes et
glaciers sont vraiment très très
important pour le tourisme mais il a
aussitôtre facteurs économiques parce
que en Suisse l'énergie hydroélectrique
est très très importante et la plupart
du lots pour les pour l'énergie
hydraulique électrique viande des
glaciers ça veut dire qu'on est glaciers
fondent les barrages sont moi remplis et
là il aura sûrement des conséquences sur
la production hydroélectrique au fil de
ses études le chercheur Mathias Husse de
l'Université du Zurich a vu d'immenses
glaciers diminuer en longueur et en
épaisseur les recherches ont même cessé
sur de plus petits glaciers faute de
matière à étudier
selon lui le phénomène qui l'attribue
entre autres à l'impact des changements
climatiques à quoi inquiéter au-delà des
frontières suisses alors on regarde les
Alpes comme le château d'eau de l'Europe
les plus grands fleuves de l'Europe
viennent des Alpes et comme ça ils
viennent des glaciers et la disparition
des glaciers aura sûrement une
conséquence assez importante sur nos
pensées
de perdre son caractère de château d'eau
c'est la calepin qui est en train de
voir son identité glaciaire disparaître
toutes ces grandes faces nord tous ces
itinéraires glaciaires qu'on a parcouru
pendant trois quatre cinq générations et
bien par certains aspects ils sont en
train de disparaître eux aussi
pour des guides d'expérimenté comme
Bertrand et Jérémy gentizont la fonte
des glaciers vient avec le besoin de
s'adapter dans gélier aux chutes de
pierre et naissance de crevasses sur la
glace il faut revoir fréquemment le
trajet des randonnées pendant le
processus il est lancé c'est quelque
chose contre lequel même si on stoppait
les émissions de gaz à effet de
l'atmosphère il continuerait mais ce
qu'on peut faire nous c'est déjà prendre
conscience de ce qui se passe l'ampleur
des changements essayer de chercher
pourquoi ces changements ils ont lieu
donc prendre conscience en fait que nous
on est quand même une partie centrale du
problème et puis travailler là-dessus
en Suisse en France et en Italie des
efforts de préservation ont été tentés
comme l'installation de couverture de
protection sur les glaciers il y a
vraiment des blocs il faut pas trop
regarder
à cette importante transformation
hyperspectives sont peu encourageantes
pour les prochaines générations je me
sens assez chanceux de pouvoir avoir
accès à ça parce que je me dis bien que
les prochaines générations peut-être
dans 20 ans 15 ans elles auront pas du
tout la chance de connaître ça donc moi
je suis tellement en ce changement puis
je l'encre dans ma mémoire et je comme
ça je pourrais le retranscrire plus loin